tardes
una sensación
más de 5 años
es un ciclo
música y poesía
puede darse o suceder
d
no es una
él
de lo sensorial
que de la razón
a su vez todo esto se trata de
interacción construir un mundo propio de
manera colectiva
por ello les voy a pedir que cuando
señale así hacia ustedes
me pregunten con voz de zombie
hambriento que es frescura
una dádiva mental es destripar lo usual
lo que la raza necesitaba el instinto
enseñándose un gesto pervertido de
autogestión la expresión al servicio de
cada uno
no me dejen en banda porque les voy a
volver a pedir que me pregunten
perfecto ya quiere decir que lo
incorporan
bueno hagamos un repaso
corría 2013 yo era un periodista
free-lance o cantante y actor casi
retirado retirado
y me ofrecen
perdón después si ahora sabía poco
tenía un par de textos con frases
inconexas y ahora si me ofrecen producir
una fecha
no me importa realmente que sea un
domingo el ofrecimiento acepte
ciegamente
va a tener nombre el evento me preguntan
pleno diciembre tres de la tarde el aire
acondicionado no funcionaba se derretían
las paredes
que necesito ahora mismo
sin más se bautiza frescura
y el 22 de diciembre se cristaliza en la
primera edición
van ya muchas ediciones en todas utilice
la lectura en vivo para probar textos
para su edición y corrección basándome
en reacciones o caras del público bien
hay dos micro mundos en frescura
abstractos aunque al menos para mí muy
reales
uno primero es la impro gracia
ceros de fino
forma de vida que aborda el contexto
ante todo como posibilidad
es transmitir y contagiar el espíritu
romanticista militante como si les
dijera luis alberto spinetta
tirarse y luego saber si había agua o no
algo que procuro sigue ocurriendo
edición a edición
hay un impulso inconsciente que acompaña
y quiere cambiar algo
es mezclar improvisación con democracia
es cruzar una avenida de voces con el
fin de dejarse atropellar por lo que
venga
el otro micro mundo
es
el trapo ético
el trapo ético surge el año pasado
gracias a hernán snyder con él
confeccionamos las bases musicales del
trapo y que bueno se ensaya en vivo
eso es importantísimo se ensaya en vivo
y las utilizamos por primera vez para
presentar mi segundo poemario el año
pasado en la feria internacional del
libro de buenos aires
y bueno algo muy importante el trapo
ético es que
sirve
para experimentar
formas nuevas
corría corría corría con mi a escribir
poesía corría corría cordial corre a
escribir pues ir intentando pasillos que
digamos permaneces como buscando galas
en los pies
por caso interpretar por ella
escribir
me dicen las excusas que aún quedan
gotas sienten que yacen cristales los
rincones de reales en pero vuelcan
locuras al cuadro
ubicación
para no dejar las palabras corría corría
corría corre a escribir poesías corría y
corría y corría escribir poesías él pero
vuelcan locuras al cuadro y calló para
no alejar las palabras pero hualcán
locuras al cuadro y cayó para no dejarme
de la fama
corría y corría corría escribir poesía
con correa correa correa escribir poesía
pues tú rico rico en xi'an
[Risas]
un día más
y correa correa correa corrida escribir
poesía
quiero puedan disfrutar la disrupción si
alguien quiere entender todo esto le
diría que se vuelva a su casa repito no
es para repito es para sentir no quieran
saber todo
comparto algunas frases que habitan
frescura
persona con amigo imaginario es enferma
muchas personas con mismo amigo
imaginario religión
lo esencial es invisible a los troskos
maurice este
o alanis
maurice 7 o alanis
el dedo es unisex
es el miedo stur icex
que consciente 57
qué inconsistente
que inconsciente inconsciente
lean
todo lo que puedan comida para la mente
ortiz
o logró que dejen entrar la poesía a
nuestro día a día o gen guitarra negra
único libro de spinetta que dice entre
otras maravillas
ignoro quién era ser yo mismo
quien se atrevió a venir en mí
pero sé quién soy ahora y soy un corazón
una boca
y un espíritu
en el mismo luis tras enterarse que
había paparazzis esperándolo se colgó un
cartel en el pecho que decía leer basura
daña la salud lea libros y fue tapa
ahora sí voy a despedir con el texto que
cierra mi primer poemario antes decirle
o darles las gracias por estar hay que
estar que nadie te la cuente qué pasa
que nadie te la cuente
este texto se llama poesía dura y está
dedicado al turrón navideño olvidado en
la alacena que encontrase en marzo
va a ser duro de roer pero algo vas a
sacar para poder calmar la lija gula o
bajón
poesía dura dice así
tiempo tengo para son ir
sino que se algo concluye
gastón racconto habla con flashback
primo lejano del feedback
mucho creía que si era poeta no usaba
desodorante así la retórica simula se
importa
párrafo aparte de si me cimiento
y entre recital genital
arpía como patético
por obra y gracia para su caso
cuál es miguel bosé en composé juvenil
paradigma de lo caótico lee como si no
existiera chiquito inocuo gana métrica
tétrica cuerpo a cuerpo el mío no me
deja tranquilo será que soy mi cuerpo
la poesía dura invade evade con su ritmo
los huecos sin nada donde la gente
quiere ser
desnuda ideas que sin ella me serían al
igual que pisa la poesía agrada o agrede
forma por pido enloquecer
vacía generalidad todo es distante o
cómplice
cuando muera me convertiré en buena
persona
el silencio en salud nunca marx
estoy más gordo pero te amo más y menos
excéntrico te lo puse en el pasacalle
estoy hay crisis pero por partes
estoy saliendo de una relación mañana te
llamo
podemos repetir con un poco
unidad ante lo inmundo de las grietas es
ir a ibiza 7 pronunciar bien bulls &
jalapeño del decir pañal poético es una
nueva forma sin forma de construir
cultura esa frescura
[Aplausos]